take a look at this comment thanks to
the name above that suddenly get money
back from scammers so a certain Nathan
Tech 70 on Instagram helped someone to
recover their money from scammers and
here's another comment thank you for
being a great example of leadership to
me I got the twenty thousand dollars
last night and the best hacker Authority
Jack helps someone earn a whole twenty
thousand dollars
and here's another one and another and
another and another and this is only the
comments on our Channel I'm sure you see
similar comments on YouTube all the time
on this guy's Channel
and on that one
and on this one too
but in truth all these comments they're
a scam and we can actually support this
statement because we've carried out our
own investigation we wrote to several
such individuals we took screenshots of
all conversations and played the fall in
order to expose them and in order to
check their honesty until the very end
we even paid one of them for the work in
the next 20 minutes we'll tell you how
to play cat and mouse with scammers they
thought they were playing us when in
fact the joke was on them
foreign
[Music]
let's start with Nathan it would be much
easier to write in the comments
then to write thank you to the name
above
why have they done this
well
author of these comments obviously knows
that they are spamming in the comments
and of course usually channels block
spam
for example the owner of the channel can
insert Instagram into the list of
blocked words to get around this
blocking hundreds of accounts are
created with links in the username the
same goes for other typical signs of
spam caps lock well why shout an Emoji
Emoji Emoji in short this should already
be a sign of spam
let's get to know Nathan we went to his
Instagram he has almost 1300 followers
and 81 posts and in general it looks
like a normal page
so what does he do as he writes himself
he recovers access to different social
media accounts to Instagram to email
accounts to Facebook by the way there's
often big problems with English in these
posts for example gamil instead of Gmail
there should also be a warning sign most
scammers as a rule have pretty bad
grammar let's take a look at these posts
anonymous hackers crypto semantic
computers
clearly they are trying to impersonate
hacker groups in general he tries to
come off like a cool hacker although
with such a guys he can probably only
trick children let's send him a message
now you'll see a real conversation this
is a screen recording we made out that
some scammers stole the password to our
Steam account
hey can you recover a stolen account my
Steam account has been stolen could you
help me
yes I can help you send me the picture
of the problem you're having on your
account send me the link of the account
and make it fast
it was stolen my password doesn't fix I
do not know how it happened
he's ready to help me but he convinces
me that I need to buy some kind of magic
flash drive
it's okay I will help but I do charge
for service feel payment will be charged
for the purchasing of the fitted
equipment needed before I can proceed
further
equipment what do you mean
Urban software code I don't know what it
is I don't understand anything in this
area can you tell me in more detail
this is what I'm talking about
our partner says that he has a friend
who sells these flash drives which have
a special code for the hacking of any
social media accounts and these flash
drives are apparently single use so in
order to get back into your hacked
accounts you need to buy one of these
magic memory sticks are you first choice
yes it is used for hacking down accounts
if we get one of these your account will
be recovered
if this flash drive contains some kind
of hacking program how could it be
bought online yes I contained the
software using hacking down lost and
disabled account to convince us that he
is a real professional Nathan shows a
screenshot of some website
now look carefully this is not just a
screenshot from the internet in the
search bar is a link that Nathan Tech 70
received from us this is alarming but
how can we pay
attention to the fact that he asks us to
send payment as family and friends and
then asks us to send a screenshot as
proof of transfer he also constantly
crushes us to send the money faster
where would you order this flash drive
how soon will it be delivered to you
delivered today my agent is close by I
don't work with people far from me and
we need to start the process ASAP and
also tries to convince us that he will
definitely return our account to us and
all this is 100 legal is it legal yes
it's legal as soon as we get the
software code everything will be solved
mom you know I don't really have time of
course it's obvious that no money should
be sent to him the signs of a scammer
are there in vast numbers for example on
his Instagram accounts the first photo
on his page is dated from the 27th of
March 2022 so the page is pretty new and
what about this certificate certified
ethical hacking courses in ethical
hacking do genuinely exist but it seems
like there's something not quite right
about this certificate look carefully at
the text there's a link to a website
visible on it
diploma-degree.com let's have a look at
it the site doesn't work anymore but if
you Google the web address then it's
obvious that this is a fake degree
Builder seriously we decided to randomly
check a few of the photos on the page it
was easy to find the original sources on
the web
this is a photo from an article in 2016
and this is a screenshot from a video
from the YouTube channel of an
Indonesian hacker who has three
subscribers do you remember the site
which you showed us in our message the
interface seems familiar to me such
videos used to pop up on Tick Tock Bingo
the site address is even visible here
although it doesn't work anymore we
found a similar site it's super simple
I'm going to try to hack a page on
Facebook without the help of Nathan Tech
70. I know the email address which is
linked to the page and I know the
password to it let's begin the hack
see to get a password you need to click
on one of the four buttons below
all four links lead to third-party sites
which are offering questionable services
but I won't use them the fact is that
email displayed here does not actually
match the one to which the Facebook page
is linked this is 100 a scam
Nathan asked us to let him know when we
are ready to make the payments take note
that he has changed the email address
associated with his Paypal
I would Hazard a guess that in this way
he is either trying to pressure us or he
creates new wallets because the old ones
are blocked for fraud okay Mom when is
the possible are you making the payment
because I will need to change my PayPal
mail then we stopped contacting him and
Nathan began to harass us he sent us a
message three days in a row a day later
he finally bothered to ask us for the
email attached to the steam account
let's give him the silent treatment
again
hello Mom do you still need my help you
let me know send me the email you links
to the steam account
a day later Nathan Tech 70 has still not
calmed down and now his messages have
taken on a slightly angry tone telling
us that we should let him know if we no
longer require services
if you're not interested let me know now
I won't bother myself on UK's okay okay
bye
in the end he writes okay bye apparently
he finally realized that the fish had
slipped off the hook
[Music]
now we're going to move on to another
scammer his name is legit bills and he
sells fake documents here is his spam
comment hi there just to let you know I
have received the passport and state ID
you made for me and I'm very happy with
them thank you for such a super smooth
deal I will be back legit bills prefers
to conduct his business over Telegram
this is a very convenient way of
communicating with scammers because it's
possible to delete not only your
messages but also the messages of your
partner so we asked legit bills to
prepare a German passport for us hi can
you make me a German passport I saw any
comments on YouTube that you are engaged
in the manufacturer of passports yeah it
depends on the possible you want is it
scannable or unscannable passport in
return you'll need to pay 1 500 euros
plus payments in Bitcoin complete
anonymity
scramble passport is the best because if
it gets scanned by the official it will
go free without any issue it's just 1500
Euros what kind of help do you need from
me besides payments and where can I
transfer the money I will need your info
that will be applied on the passport
that's all I need from you passport is
made by Bitcoin
the wait for the passport is 72 hours
the scammer promised to send it by post
it's simple and easy legit builds
assures us it reminds us that forging
documents is his business and he would
never try to deceive his customers how
long will it take to prepare a passport
will you send it to me by mail
it doesn't take much time just in 72
hours you
did that's where I ship it to you
how can I be sure that you won't deceive
me 1 500 euros is a lot of money to see
this is my business that I've been doing
for so many years I'm going to show you
what is called a scalable passport
seeing my doubts legit Bill sends a
video of a document that he allegedly
made it will subsequently delete this
video but we managed to save it to our
phone
legit builds calls his business
legitimate and says that all his
previous clients were satisfied with the
documents they received I'm only in for
serious and legit business all those who
receive their passport from those I
deliver the best ID
now I wonder at what point the payment
takes place legit bill says that he
needs to receive the money first in
order to purchase some software and
other materials he needs yeah you have
to make the payment then I do your work
I have to purchase some software and
tools to make your work done that's why
I have to receive payments before
proceeding on work and in the next 24
hours after payment and receiving your
details and all that then I will show
you what you pay for which is 100 this
is a risky transaction so we agree that
we'll transfer 1 000 Euros as an advance
payment
this suits him because it's better to
get at least something sounds dangerous
maybe I will pay for the software and
the other things that you have to
purchase I
have bought them and will give you the
rest
let's do it this way this way if you did
not believe me then pay up front which
is just 1 000 Euros then I will purchase
all I have to do then after you see what
you paid for then you balance up legit
bills convinces us that he can't start
work without receiving the money which
in general makes sense now we're going
to speak to one of his former clients so
they can confirm that legit bills isn't
a scammer can't just execute your
assignments without receiving any
upfront from you that's impossible
maybe you have clients you have worked
with before and you're satisfied can I
talk to them I'm afraid to send such a
large amount of money to a stranger this
isn't illegal business it would be happy
sharing their contact or stuff so they
can give contact to them for Assurance
about illegal business if it were to be
you would you be happy I'd give out
details about you to others to contact
you but his answer is pretty predictable
he admits that his business is illegal
although he already assured us of its
legitimacy nobody who has fake documents
is going to want to talk about it legit
Bill sends another video showing a fake
passport
foreign
to finally win us over the interlocutor
sends several screenshots showing thank
you messages from customers
maybe it's Photoshop or Bots notably the
upper part of the screen where the
current time is located is cropped most
likely these pictures are just blanks
for the more scrupulous customers
please note that these messages were
sometimes received just 10 minutes apart
wow favorite to you almost every 10
minutes some paid asking for packages
and some receive sharing gratitude it's
normal daily routine
he also sends us a couple of completed
passports by the way the scammer
actually sends us these photos with all
the personal data video yes the details
are blocked out right now but that's
because we did it ourselves if we were
undercover police officers then we could
already have caused a lot of trouble for
his clients however we think that these
people don't exist at all and here's why
we try to look for photographs of these
passports online and bingo Google search
once again helps us out
you can see on deviantarts.com that's a
certain Tom Joanie uses his photograph
as an example of his work just like
legit bills however it seems to me that
Tom Joanie also stole this photo from
somewhere
he has too many services in his profile
pay attention to the date of the post
December 2021
a short search leads to a website for
the production of documents
judging by the website the passport that
we received was not just made by some
guy who makes passports at home there's
a whole company doing it we did the same
search with the next photograph that
legit bill sent us we can see that he
stole this Photograph too
most likely the person who we're
speaking to actually has nothing to do
with any business that forges documents
he pretends to provide such services and
perhaps a few people take the bait
[Music]
here's one more spam comment that caught
our attention
I've been suspecting my partner for a
long time until I requested four 190
Victor on IG who helped me hack my
partner's social media and cell phone
with a certainty proof you can always
reach him out via 4192 Victor on
Instagram for 192 Victor offers a whole
array of services such as hacking social
networks and the opportunity to receive
an additional income his Instagram page
is full of video appeals from people who
have left extremely positive reviews
about him the reviews are from all
different countries in different
languages teenagers aren't just praising
some abstract hacker genius they call
him by his nickname 4192 Victor
he most likely found these teenagers
through an ad paid them a few dollars
and they then learned the text by heart
and repeated it for the camera the page
also displays a number of screenshots of
messages from his satisfied clients
there aren't many posts considering that
the Instagram account has existed for
two years already strange that in this
time 4192 Victor hasn't been blocked
we told Victor about our desire to earn
money but we added that we only have 50
at our disposal naturally he offered to
double the amount for us
I heard that you can help get some money
can you help me
welcome to 4192 Victor page where your
interest is
[Music]
are we recover your money back to you
which country are you from I'm from the
UK I don't have much money but I want to
make money how can you help me lady I am
a professional investor and risk
management with 10 years experience I
can triple your investments in less than
three days if you are seriously ready
now for my service
last fifty dollars what do I need to do
to at least double my money is there a
way to end with such a small amount lady
I will help you out with 50
I receive steam gifts cards
[Music]
card gold card as payments
you can purchase the car from the store
in your country or I can send you a link
to purchase the card online once I
receive and confirm your payment in less
than one days I will double the 50 USD
100 USD and I promise you after my
service you we recommend me to your
friends and family for more service the
frauds game is simple Victor asked you
to buy a gift card and offers you a
choice between a steam gift card an
iTunes gift card or a razor gold card
how long can I get 100 will the payment
be made to my card or account I still
don't understand how it works
once you make the payment now in less
than one day I'm across the car details
to transfer the money back to you to you
double I always wonder why do people
fall for this today not for a second
think why should Victor do business
publish ads and take money from someone
if he can actually double any amount why
doesn't Victor just sit and double his
own money Victor doesn't disclose his
email or any personal data that's why
the scheme uses gift cards the code for
activating the card comes to our inbox
we send Victor a screenshot and he
simply activates or resells the card
purchased with our money I have already
told you earlier we should make the
payments here we received PIN codes to
your mail screenshot the codes here on
my page the code is your payment for my
service we ask in what miraculous way
will he double our money he replies that
he trades Forex together with a team of
brilliant Traders and allegedly invests
our money and doubles it in a day so we
decided to send Victor 50 euros we were
well aware that we'll never see this
money again and that Victor is 100 a
fraudster the main reason that we spent
this money is so that you can see with
your own eyes what will happen after you
God forbid send money to any of these
scammers you'll say they will refuse to
fulfill their start of the bargain and
how they'll explain this away
we bought a Razer gold gift card here's
the email with the codes that we
received we took screenshots and sent
them to Victor
we send in the code and
and
he actually didn't immediately block us
as we assumed
look he asked for the details of our
card in order to transfer the 100
tomorrow as promised great
in less than 124s your investment will
be double send me your bank details
I'm so happy I will be looking forward
to my money send me your banking details
we definitely don't recommend that you
send your credit card details in any
case never tell anyone your CVC which is
on the back of your card most likely
Victor will not be able to access a bank
card having only its details but many of
these people then sell this information
to Carters criminals who make copies of
credit cards but we're one step ahead of
him let's generate some card details you
can easily find a generator on the
internet just type in the necessary
parameters and get the data if Victor
really wants to transfer money to us he
just won't be able to do it then he'll
send a message to let us know about the
problem
but something tells me that this won't
happen
[Applause]
[Music]
2026 sorry it took so long I'm at work
okay great please just exercise patience
in less than 24 hours you we received
the increments fancy wonderful I'm
racing in spite of our concerns Victor
does not ask us for our CVC or pin code
he just asks us to be patient and wait
for 100 to arrive in our accounts the
next day we can still write to Victor he
is still in touch and responds to our
messages the next day he assures us that
we will soon receive our return on
investments allegedly Victor trades on
the stock exchange from Canada and will
soon send us money let's just wait for
the specified time
[Music]
hey what's up
lady you know we are in Canada different
time from yours we are still 9am and we
are trading Forex your investment you're
right I would have to write less than 24
hours time is almost up lady I know I am
using Canada time to trade your
investment in Forex please in less than
four hours your account will be credited
with double your investment thank you
when the time comes 4192 Victor contacts
us and informs us that in order for him
to withdraw our investment income we
need to deposit another 100 and then we
will receive 300 to our card
lady congratulations your payment on
investment will still be confirmed
because the Forex Trading between
Germany and United States is still
floating your investment is showing 90
already once it got to 100 my investment
team we put out your return on
investments
but for the investment in the Forex
Market to pull out so I can transfer
your return investment you we have to
put more 100 USD when she puts more 100
USD then we can now withdraw 300 USD to
please you really have to make the 100
USD so the total money can be withdrawn
double back to you in less than three
hours
once you make available this 100 USD
your investment will be 100 complete and
the double in investment will be
transferred to you he makes mention of
Forex and an entire investment team most
likely this is a template message that
he sends to everyone in order to squeeze
even more money out of a gullible person
this is what all scammers do realizing
that a person has trusted them they will
milk them until he comes to his senses
his friends bring him to his senses or
he runs out of money
give me back my fifty dollars I believe
you and you deceived me in response we
demanded the money back and of course we
didn't get anything Victor began to
claim that 300 is the minimum amount he
can withdraw lady I am a man of
integrity and impeccable capability I
deliver as promised your money is in the
system please I know how you feel
because I am a human as well there is
nothing I can do because the least
amount that is allowed to be withdrawal
by system is 300 USD that is why I
pleaded Vegeta and 100 USD to the total
money with interest vb300 USD as Allowed
by the system please I plead with you to
understand me so I can put smiles on
your face forever
complaints about your accounts and then
he blocked us
I
of course if you find yourself in such a
situation you can report the scammers
page and so we did but remember that
Victor's page is already two years old
there have definitely already been
complaints but Victor continues to trick
people
every year all around the world people
are scammed out of millions of dollars
reports from the U.S Federal Trade
Commission show that scammers are
increasingly using social media to trick
Us in 2021 one in four people who
reported losing money as a result of
fraud indicated that they had
encountered fraud online in total over
the past year U.S citizens handed over
770 million dollars to fraudsters
let's summarize the results of our
investigation what unites people who
make money via scams and how can you
protect yourself from them first
carefully study the profile of the
individual in question if it is new or
there are few photos and comments on it
it's most likely a fraudster
secondly there's no such thing as free
money just accept it only scammers can
make quick money if you fall for their
tricks thirdly most locally the
fraudster will try to make you rush into
paying for the product or service you
are interested in he may even try to
call you
and finally whatever happens never
transfer money to strangers well we can
say always think for yourself
and treat any offers as easy earnings as
critically as possible this is your main
defense
[Music]